bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 24 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal votre
actualité locale chaque jour ont entouré
de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite lé titre de
cette édition
dans le cadre du mois de
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant les acteurs
du financement viennent rencontrer les
porteurs de projets de l'université
paris saclay
aujourd'hui l'opération phone my start
up avait lieu à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'occasion d'informer les étudiants
futurs entrepreneurs sur le sujet
l'armement de la police municipale en
question à voisins le bretonneux le
conseiller municipal d'opposition de la
commune olivier à son os soit armer les
policiers municipaux de la ville
l'homme politique a lancé le débat lors
du dernier conseil municipal les détails
à suivre
et comment prévenir le suicide
accompagné les familles mais aussi les
salariés confrontés à cette dure
problématique
le centre hospitalier
jean-martin-charcot temps de répondre à
ces questions en organisant des journées
de conférences auprès des personnels de
santé
la dernière était axée sur le suicide en
institution comme dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et aujourd'hui 24 mars
étudiants et personnels de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
ont voté pour désigner leurs
représentants aux conseils centraux et
notamment au conseil d'administration
une élection qui permettra ensuite le 10
mai de désigner le nouveau président ils
sont deux à briguer ce poste jean luc
vaissière sortant et son ancien
colistier didier guillemot médecins et
chercheurs
jean-luc vestiaires mettant en avant son
bilan et notamment le redressement
financier d'un établissement au bord de
la faillite en 2013 il évoque aussi la
rationalisation de l'utilisation des
locaux
didier guillemot lui entend en cas de
victoire mettre en place une gouvernance
collégiale est imposé lui vécu comme un
partenaire incontournable de paris
saclay pour ce vote des urnes étaient
installés sur les différents sites
jusqu'à 19h les et résultats seront
connus dans la journée de demain
vendredi
nous y reviendrons et les étudiants
continuent leur mobilisation contre la
loi le projet de loi du travail après
les mouvements des 9 et 17 mars
il appelait à se rassembler à nouveau
aujourd'hui à paris malgré la décision
du gouvernement de modifier certains
articles polémiques
hier l'union des étudiants communistes
de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tracter devant
l'université pour mobiliser à nouveau on
écoute
arnaud carbone secrétaire de l'ud essais
il était au micro de camille lambert
quelques modifications qui ont été
faites néanmoins l'essentiel des des
réformes rétrogrades qu'elle comprend à
savoir la possibilité pour un patron de
diminuer arbitrairement le salaire la
possibilité d'augmenter le temps de
travail sans augmentation de salaire la
possibilité de radier les onze heures de
pause toutes les 24 heures de travail
tout ce qu'il fait avec la fin là
quelles idées rétrogrades de 7,2 cette
loi est toujours présente et donc en
fait cette réforme
enfin cette cette relecture de la loi en
fait ne met que ce ne sont que des
miettes de pain et nous vous en avions
déjà parlé vous savez le mois de mars et
le mois de l'entrepreneuriat étudiant
depuis le 10 mars les acteurs de
paris-saclay se mobilisent tous les
jeudis pour aider et favoriser la
création d'entreprises dans le cadre
justement du mois de l'entrepreneuriat
aujourd'hui à l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les jeunes
entreprises avaient rendez-vous tout
l'après-midi pour fun my start-up une
rencontre entre les financeurs et les
startups du territoire camille lambert
pour ce reportage
comment financer sa création
d'entreprise pour y répondre jeudi 24
mars les porteurs de projets avaient
rendez-vous à l'université de versailles
saint quentin pour l'événement phare en
mass start up organisé par startin'
saclay et financé technologie cette date
était adressé en particulier aux jeunes
entrepreneurs
le problème de du jeune qui va se lancer
c'est qu'il n'est pas forcément bien
informée donc il essaie justement dû
fournir cette information supplémentaire
pour l'accompagner dans sa démarche de
création kiss kiss bang bang ou encore
la banque publique d'investissement une
dizaine de financeurs ont exposé leurs
propositions aux différentes start up du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et du plateau de saclay c'est partie de
notre rôle est d'accompagner
les créateurs d'entreprises et de les
aider dans leurs projets et de les
renseigner sur tout sur ce qu'il est
possible d'avoir en termes de l'entente
de financement à leur stade à leur tête
d'avancé
je suis porteur de projet d'une petite
start up qui s'intéressent à l'écrit
fication orval en africain je suis venu
me renseigner sur comment comment se
financer comme en récupérer un peu
d'argent et puis aussi à développer un
peu le réseau rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes
moi j'ai lancé avec deux associés une
start up qui s'appelle work is wrkz est
on
démultiplier la force commerciale des
entreprises grâce à des étudiants qui
sont auto-entrepreneurs je suis venu ici
aujourd'hui pour rencontrer du monde
pourrait changer surtout une vingtaine
de start up étaient présentes pour ce
moment des changes après la question du
financement se pose la question du
développement de l'entreprise
quelles structures peuvent les
accompagner pour concrétiser leur projet
des réponses seront apportées le 31 mars
à orsay dans le cadre de l'événement
foster my start up et nous allons à
présent par les emplois dans notre
entretien ce soir nous recevons barbara
nommage et bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la
présidente de l'association a des vies
donc à déville association d aide au
développement de l'emploi de vendeur à
domicile indépendant alors le mercredi
30 mars à moules se tiendra le jeu brink
donc c'est un forum de
l'intercommunalité de galim au long qui
regroupe en delhumeau le basin entre
autres herbes ville crêpière
feucherolles chavenay et saint nom la
bretèche
alors pour la première fois sur ce forum
de l'emploi se mêleront des enseignes
qui recrutent des salariés et celles qui
recrutent des vendeurs à domicile
indépendants
les représentants des grandes enseignes
qui recrutent des indépendants sont
membres de la dvi et certains habitent
château bois d'arcy encore fontenay le
fleury
c'est une grande première pour vous et
vous êtes d'ailleurs co organisatrice de
ce salon
tout à fait c'est une grande première
parce que on voit souvent des forums de
l'emploi et du recrutement où il y as
uniquement des enseignes qui recrutent
en des salariés et d'autre part
également des forums de l'emploi qui
recrutent des vendeurs à domicile
indépendants
là c'est une grande première
effectivement les deux vont enfin se
mêler alors comment cela va se dérouler
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu
plus donc le job ruines aura lieu donc
le 30 mars de 10h à 18h à maule dans la
salle des fêtes à la place henri dunant
donc il y aura des temps forts des
conférences en fait de présentation de
métiers dont j'animerai d'ailleurs une
des conférences dont 15 heures le matin
et une autre probablement donc l'après
midi le but en fait c'est de présenter
le métier de parler des caractéristiques
des caractéristiques pardon juridique
des conditions d'exercice et puis nous
parlerons également de mon association
donc j'ai créé depuis cette année depuis
janvier alors justement un petit peu
votre session seat
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
qui allez un petit peu son rôle et
pourquoi vous l'avez crée donc son rôle
donc la dfb dei c'est une association
qui regroupe dvd i des vendeurs à
domicile indépendants de toutes
enseignes confondues
on a une vocation effectivement on est
pour l'instant dans les yvelines
effectivement on a des adhérents
également dans le 91 dans le 93 points
on en a un peu partout le but en fait
ces ensembles de soutenir pour sa portée
en fait les forces des uns et des autres
on se forme par exemple s'il ya des
personnes de tout horizon qui viennent
par exemple dans l'informatique dans
dans le management et ensemble en fait
on
on crée des ateliers de formation entre
nous on va là on s'apporte les uns les
autres on soutient on essaie de
promouvoir le métier on collabore avec
les communes et les différentes
associations dead au retour à l'emploi
afin de promouvoir le métier de pouvoir
élargir la palette d'offres d'emploi
lors de ces forums pour démontrer qu'il
y a énormément d'emplois alors le métier
de vendeur à domicile et mon nom et
chacun apporte ses qualités valence il
ya des professeurs ils apportent leur
pédagogie et c'est l'ancien manager il
ya aussi une grosse partie aux matériels
dans votre dans la de la profession tout
à fait parce que le rôle du v10 et de
diffuser le produit ou le service de
l'enseignent qu'il représente son second
rôle est effectivement de coopter de
franchise et d'autres vd et pour ce
faire effectivement il va former levée
des parrains il va former donc de
nouveau vaidéhi jusqu'à ce qu'ils
puissent effectivement lui aussi donc
faire ce métier et donc il ya une grosse
partie management parce qu'une fois ce
groupe qui sera constituée et bien il va
falloir le suivre les dés le guider et
donc effectivement une grosse partie
management
comment avez-vous eu l'idée de monter
justement ce concept c'est très
particulier c'est vraiment sur une
petite niche
oui effectivement parce qu' il existe
donc une fédération de vente directe en
france mais celle ci réunit les
enseignes et non les représentants de
ces enseignes
donc aujourd'hui moi j'ai le souhait par
l'intermédiaire de cette association
c'est de rassembler les représentants de
ces deux enseignes pour qu'ils se
sentent moins isolés plus soutenue et
puis voilà on fait vraiment partie d'un
groupe et qui se soutiennent il ya un
code éthique également dans notre
association c'est de ne pas dénigrer les
enseignes des unes des autres donc après
un an d'existence quel bilan tirez vous
à ce que la session a beaucoup grandi
elle grandit elle essaye de se faire
connaître on continue nos efforts et
puis on essaye de on a créé un site on a
une page facebook également et donc ça
permet effectivement de promouvoir
l'association et puis tout le monde peut
s'y inscrire qui sont les personnes
concernées c'est havas s'adresse
vraiment à tout le monde tout on peut se
dire je veux devenir vendeur à domicile
indépendant tout le monde parce que ce
métier ne nécessite aucun pré requis
aucun diplôme
puisque on y rentre par franchise par
parrainage et la personne le parrain est
censé également formés donc
effectivement lui il a reçu une
formation de son propre parent et puis
voilà ça continue comme ça c'est une
activité à plein temps c'est incomplet
mon emploi comment vous laisse bien
souvent les levés dei qui rentre
en tant que vaidéhi il commence en se
disant je vais compléter mes revenus
mais au fur et à mesure il se prend au
jeu et puis c'est surtout selon la
motivation de chacun on est tous
différent peut il rentre effectivement
pour un complément de revenu et ensuite
on peut envisager effectivement une
belle carrière
d'ailleurs lors du forum pendant la
conférence deux intervenants ils
passeront afin de délivrer de leurs
expériences effectivement ils ont
commencé en tant que complément de
revenu est aujourd'hui et on a un
d'ailleurs qui quitte l'entreprise dans
laquelle il a travaillé pendant quatorze
ans pour voilà certainement une belle
carrière l'attend moi donc ça peut être
vraiment des étudiants jusqu'à des
personnes qui souhaitent posséder des
femmes qui sont au foyer vraiment fonds
d'un peu tout le monde fectivement
surtout dans dans certaines campagnes
effectivement bon le fléau du chômage il
nous ne nous épargne pas et
effectivement dans certaines de ces
zones justement comme il n'y a pas
d'emploi effectivement ça peut être une
forme d'emploi une forme de complément
de revenu dans un premier temps et puis
une belle carrière
c'est ce que vous mettez en avant sur
votre site internet donc la vente à
domicile fait partie d'une des solutions
pour lutter contre le chômage
justement dans les milieux ruraux
trequesser dans ce cas là c'est plus
facile pour les gens justement d'aller
vers d'autres personnes de proposer ces
services là qu'en ville voilà et puis en
plus il ya un aspect également des
changes
parce qu'il ya beaucoup aussi de
personnes âgées qui sont isolées qui
aime bien également assister à des
petites réunions comme ça ils font ils
reçoivent du monde à la maison et puis
bon voilà c'est quelque chose de très
bien c'est avec c dans l'air dans l'air
de l'époque
voilà une solution la fois pour contrer
le chômage comment une fois qu'on vous a
rejoint comment vous fonctionnez
commencent à se distribuer un petit peu
le rôle d'aider des gens qui vont alors
les membres peuvent être juste membres
utilisateurs vous membres actifs donc
chacun est en mesure de proposer un
atelier
selon son expérience il en avait envie à
aucune forme d'obligation c'est vraiment
selon la motivation de la personne donc
voilà si elle est motivée à vouloir
effectivement donner de son temps pour
animer un atelier très bien pourquoi pas
ou sinon elle est juste membres
utilisatrices et dans ces cas-là elle
adhère effectivement et puis on décolle
on a un nouveau forum de l'emploi et du
recrutement et bien des personnes sont
informées en priorité donc la vente à
domicile pour lutter contre le chômage
serait qu'on n'imagine pas qu'il y ait
autant de perspectives c'est vraiment un
secteur en pleine croissance où il ya
des possibilités d'évolution
ah oui tout à fait de belles
perspectives d'évolution sachez que sur
l'année 2015
il l avait d ea a généré plus de 4
milliards de chiffre d'affaires pour 6
124 mille vaidéhi en france donc c'est
vraiment un secteur en pleine croissance
et voilà qui gagne à être connu si on
souhaite vous rejoindre si on a
intéressé par votre session comme on
comment s'y prendre comment faire alors
on a une page facebook un donc à dvd
on a également un site internet donc
www.hadopi.fr voilà donc n'hésitez pas
contactez nous
voilà merci beaucoup barbara d'imagés
ailleurs je le rappelle le salon que je
bouquine aura lieu le 30 mars de 11h à
18h à maule et vous serez bien
évidemment présentes il y a voilà le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran n'hésitez pas à aller jeter
un oeil pour avoir plus d'informations
et les inscriptions sont ouvertes donc
il faut aller sur le site joe breen
point org est entendu merci beaucoup
tout autre sujet à présent nous allons
parler santé prévenir le suicide
accompagné les familles mais aussi les
personnels depuis deux ans le centre
hospitalier jean-martin-charcot organise
des journées de conférences et des
tables rondes auprès des personnels de
santé celle de cette année était axée
sur le suicide en institution dont jeu
difficiles un problème difficile comme
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques et
mélanie poker pour ce reportage
soutenir les personnes touchées par un
suicide en institution éviter les effets
d'imitation c'est ce qu'on appelle la
postvention le thème choisi par le
centre hospitalier jean marie charcot
lors de sa conférence annuelle
alors la postvention et l ensemble des
démarches et ou de dispositifs qu'on met
en place à la suite d'une tentative de
suicide ou de suicides avérés
donc tout ce qui concerne aller soutient
qu'en peut amener aux personnes qui sont
concernées affecté par cet événement en
2011 plus de 11000 suicides ont été
enregistrés en france et les milieux
médical uv sont aussi concernés même si
les données ne sont pas connues c'est
difficile les institutions sont là pour
protéger pour aider et quand ça arrive
mais on est confronté vraiment des
situations très difficiles
donc effectivement ça reste encore un
peu tabou on espère que justement part
par le fait d'en parler par le fait de
pouvoir se soutenir les uns les autres
ça devienne ou moins et donc ça nous
rendre encore meilleurs pour accompagner
les personnes qui en ont besoin
c'est un axe de prévention du suicide
extrêmement fort
qui permet de préserver les personnels
des institutions dans leur capacité de
travail et dans leur capacité à pouvoir
continuer sur le plan personnel et donc
c'est un axe de prévention qui permet à
la fois d'accompagner le personnel est
d'accompagner les résidents ou des
patients dans les institutions
organisé en partenariat avec le
groupement d'études et prévention du
suicide
ces journées annuelles vise à former les
personnels des institutions pour mieux
accompagner les familles aient levé un
tabou et on prend à présent la direction
de voisins-le-bretonneux le conseiller
municipal d'opposition de la commune
olivier affonso voudrait armer les
policiers municipaux de la ville
l'homme politique a lancé le débat lors
du dernier conseil municipal les détails
de michael et demi d'euros et fanny
bourdillon pour les images la police
municipale de voisins bretons ne sera t
elle bientôt armés le débat a été lancé
par olivia funds au conseiller municipal
d'opposition lors du conseil municipal
du 16 février
objectif mieux protéger la population de
voisins-le-bretonneux suite aux derniers
attentats terroristes on pourrait
considérer qu effectivement voisin
bretonne est une ville sans risque il
n'y a pas de ville sans risque
actuellement on est dans un état
d'urgence je pense d'abord à nos
policiers municipaux parce que c'est
d'abord peu qui se retrouve face au
danger c'est pas nous les élus c'est la
police municipale qui se retrouve face
aux terroristes
le terrorisme ne choisit pas il ne
réfléchit pas deux secondes si c'est un
policier municipal ou six reprises à la
police nationale
aujourd'hui les cinq policiers
municipaux de voisins-le-bretonneux sont
équipés de bombes lacrymogènes de
matraques télescopiques de menottes et
de gilet pare balles de son côté la
mairie ne ferme pas le débat sur la
question et pour l abordé lors d'un
prochain conseil municipal
c'est un sujet qui a déjà été soulevé en
voisin il ya quelques années
le maire à l'époque avait fait une
demande à la préfecture qui a été refusé
aujourd'hui je pense que là mais de la
question mérite d'être posée
voilà ceci dit moi je suis assez mesuré
quand même sur le sujet je souhaite en
débattre avec avec tous les élit
évidemment ce que c'est pas un sujet
c'est pas un sujet anodin
ces derniers mois les communes du chéné
des longs cours et de rambouillet ou
tard mais leur police municipale et les
travaux continuent à montigny le
bretonneux cette fois ci c'est le poney
club et ses pairs qui s'offre une
seconde jeunesse le chantier prévoit un
agrandissement du club house de 115
mètres carrés et une mise aux normes de
la partie existante les détails avec et
sephora nos manies et fanny bourdillon
coup de jeune pour le poney club ucpa de
la ferme du manet de montigny le
bretonneux
installé depuis 1991 dans l'ancien
pavillon de chasse de la ferme du mané
le cloud va rentrer d'ici la fin du mois
de mars dans la dernière des trois
phases de réhabilitation de l'équipement
la ville est propriétaire donc des
bâtiments mais donc le poney poney club
culé cpa et donc c'est une délégation de
service public et donc dans nos
engagements la ville s'était donc
engagée à agrandir ce poney club des
travaux permettront un agrandissement
duc la base de plus de 115 mètres carrés
avec un nouveau foyer de 60 m² une
remise aux normes de la partie existante
créée il ya 25 ans est également prévue
celle ci pour répondre aux critères
d'accessibilité dès personnes à mobilité
réduite avec création d'équipements
sanitaires adaptés à la partie extension
ce qui est intéressant c'est donc de
vous il va y aura un foyer qui va faire
environ 60 mètres carrés où donc les
gens les enfants pourront dire
travailler enfin faire des activités et
où les parents pourront depuis la salle
avec une grande paroi vitrée voir depuis
sur le lapident carrière on peut voir
les enfants évoluer moi je vais être à
vie parce qu'on aura un accès pour les
handicapés pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite les parents et clients des
visiteurs
il ya de plus en plus de monde qui vient
du coup c'est bien d'agrandir aussi et
vu qu'on a déjà fait d'autres travaux
c'est bien maintenant on peut voir des
les manèges depuis l'intérieur on n'est
pas obligé l'hiver quand il pleut de
rester au bord du manège pour regarder
le nouveau bâtiment devrait être livré
d'ici l'automne prochain coût de
l'opération 6 135 mille euros et nous
recevons à présent sur ce plateau notre
journaliste sportif à michael et demi
d'euros pour son incontournable
chronique sport du jeudi bon sang mais t
elle et son forum alors dites nous quel
est le thème de votre chronique
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui c'est une
chronique sport un petit peu
particulière je vais vous parler à
d'arbitrage matteo biancucci 14 ans et
il est arbitre depuis deux ans après une
première année en football animation sur
des deux mi terrain cet hymne a été
lancé dans le grand bain
cette saison sur des matchs de l'ue 15 à
11 et passion inédites qu'il tient de
son grand père nous l'avons rencontrée
sur un match de dhr le week-end dernier
à versailles les têtes au micro de
camille lambert en fait des fois quand
vous venez chez moi va nous raconter un
peu basique sport et du coup ça m'a plu
puis je voulais essayer
du coup ben j'en suis là maintenant
alors comment il a fait pour devenir
arbitre intel alors pour devenir arbitre
le jeune matteo reçu une formation il
s'entraîne également deux fois par
semaine le mardi et le jeudi
objectif être au plus près des actions
pour mieux analyser des situations du
jeu nous donne donc les qualités pour
être un bon arbitre fondement durance
ensuite s'il faut faut être attentif à
ce qu'ils disent des observateurs du
district ou de la ligue ça dépend quel
niveau on est situé
faut bien écouter aussi pendant la
préparation et faut bien retenir aussi
aujourd'hui matteo arbitres sur des
matches de première division de district
ou sur des matchs de dhr des rencontres
avec du contact qui nécessitent le plus
souvent l'intervention de l'arbitré
ils montrent un doit donc faire preuve
d'autorité sur le terrain il nous
présente sa recette pour gérer son match
je mets un coup de sifflet donc après ça
c'est par où ou non et puis si les gens
ne se sépare pas et que ça commence à
partir en bagarre fut obligée de
fonctionner et d exclure les joueurs bat
sur tous les matches que j'ai faits pour
l'instant et c'était assez sympa assez
cool je puisse jamais eu des embrouilles
et ils comprennent
après deux premières saisons ponctuées
de succès dans son rôle de directeur du
jeu à matteo veut continuer dans cette
voie et faire de sa passion une
profession mon but à moi si d'itron
professionnel je pourrais pas arbitré le
paris saint germain ce que j'en aie
parisienne et du coup ben je pourrais
pas arbitré par email sera mon but d'
arbitrer les matches de ligue 1 matteo
pourrait peut-être devenir dans les
prochaines années le futur clément
turpin les amateurs de football le
connaissent forcément larbi tissu de la
ligue de bourgogne a été désigné en 2009
le plus jeune arbitre international 2
fifa à seulement 26 ans florent est long
il souhaite la même réussite mais c'est
singulier michael à cet âge on veut
toujours devenir footballeur et lui a
fait partie de devenir arbitre c'est
surprenant mais c'est son choix qu'il
arbitre à le psg peut être plus tard
pour l'olympique de marseille
nous le verrons nous suivrons à nous
suivrons son parcours on va à présent
ranger les cartons rouges et le sifflet
pour parler de cyclisme dans cette
émission le premier grand prix de
cyclistes de montilly bretonneux est
programmée ce dimanche 27 mars de 8h à
12h
les cyclistes réaliseront des boucles
sur un circuit de 3 km le départ et
l'arrivée seront situés avenue du parc
les sportifs emprunteront l'avenue des
prés l'avenue du général il n'y aura pas
de difficultés particulières
une centaine de cyclistes est attendue
pour cet événement et après le cyclisme
une fois n'est pas coutume on termine
cette chronique par du tir à l'arc il
faudra mais les précisions et sang froid
à magny les hameaux pour remporter la
victoire
le championnat départemental de tir à
l'arc parcours nature est organisé par
la compagnie d'arc de magny les hameaux
et le comité départemental des yvelines
sur le site de port royal des champs
les premiers tirs débuteront à 8h30 les
résultats seront annoncés a dit
heures 30 le concours et sélectif au
championnat de france 2016
un beau rendez-vous en perspective merci
à vous michael on se retrouve à la
semaine prochaine la semaine prochaine
mardi et non pas jeudi
mardi mardi et jeudi car mardi il n'y
aura lundi noir pardon il n'y aura pas
de 7,8 sport vos fans vont être un petit
peu malheureux mais du coup tous les
résultats sportifs sera alors seront à
retrouver dont la chronique sport qui
sera du coup le mardi et le jeudi avec
vous michael vous n'entrez pas ce rendez
vous sur la j'espère puisque leur jeu
serait mieux qu'ils peuvent
c'est la fin de cette édition merci nous
avoir suivis demain vous retrouvez
wilfried est enrichie pour l'essentiel
de l'actu moi je vous retrouve mardi
pour une nouvelle édition du journal je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée est
donc un très bon week end